Hello, this is Don Byron coming
to you from my palatial home
in upstate New York.
These three pieces
that I wrote are
inspired by another
native Bronx, like myself.
The great Saul Bass.
Bass is-- if you've seen
his work, you remember it.
He's the person that really
updated the whole vibe of what
you could do in the title
sequence of a movie,
and he starts with Otto
Preminger's great works
like "Man with the Golden
Arm," and continues
through not just doing
Hitchcock's stuff,
but actually being an influence
to the way it was made.
He won an Oscar for a short.
He designed several
of the corporate logos
to businesses like Bell
Telephone and United Airlines,
and for someone like me who's
a student of film music,
he's an important part of how we
get masterworks like Spartacus
and Psycho, North by
Northwest, all of those things
are shaped by this person, both
graphically and artistically.
So me, as a film composer,
which is what I really
think that I am, I just
decided to tackle 10 of these,
and these are the
first three, and I
thank MIT for commissioning them
and giving me the opportunity
to work on this music.
And that's what
these pieces are.
I mean, my influences, as
a musician and composer,
are pretty wide, but Saul
Bass, who actually grew up
less than a mile from
my parents' house
in the Bronx, which also means
he grew up less than a mile
from the place where
Abner Louima was shot.
So that's what this piece
is, and I hope you enjoy it.
[MUSIC - SAUL BASS, "WALK ON THE
WILD SIDE"]
[MUSIC - SAUL BASS, "THE
STRIKE"]
[MUSIC - SAUL BASS, "SOMETHING
WILD"]